nez qui coule gorge qui gratte
tous ces symptômes vous sont
probablement familier et pour cause la
chute des températures s'accompagne d'un
retour des virus hivernaux bien que la
période soit propice aux vieux aux
saisonniers ces derniers surviennent
dans un contexte particulier lié à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 l'an dernier
les confinements successifs ajouté au
respect des gestes-barrières ont
occasionné une circulation plus faible
de ces virus moins exposée aux bactéries
de tous les jours notre système
immunitaire pourrait s'être affaiblie
alors locaux vides 19 at il vraiment eu
d'impact sur notre immunité et
risque-t-on d'être davantage malade cet
hiver
[Musique]
grippe bronchiolite
rhinopharyngite rhume après avoir été
évitée voire presque oublier les virus
hivernaux reviennent en force
nécessitant l'intervention de notre
système immunitaire avant toute chose il
est primordial de saisir de quoi il
s'agit composé de cellules d'organes et
de tissus notre système immunitaire a
pour mission de défendre notre organisme
contre toute forme d'agression
extérieure bien souvent invisibles à
l'oeil nu nous sommes chaque jour
confrontés à des virus des bactéries ou
encore des champignons si notre système
immunitaire est relativement solide il
est toutefois loin d'être envahie et le
fait de ne pas avoir été exposé est
suffisamment habile virus et des
bactéries pendant une saison peut avoir
des conséquences sur la façon dont votre
système immunitaire va réagir vis-à-vis
d'infection futur et pas forcément
vis-à-vis des pathogènes que tout
n'avait pas rencontré c'est à dire qu'en
gros votre système immunitaire il sera
plus naïfs globalement moins bien
entraîné non seulement à réagir
vis-à-vis de nouvelles infections mais
aussi à contrôler la réponse
inflammatoire qui parfois est plus grave
que l'infection elle même comme c'est le
cas pour le communisme dans le rappelez
vous l'année dernière la france a
échappé à l'épidémie du virus de la
grippe on vous en parlait d'ailleurs
dans cet épisode de factures le
professeur patrick berche vous expliquer
alors que le lavage régulier des mains
le port du masque ainsi que la
distanciation social avec contribuer à
éviter cette épidémie c'est le constat
fait par le conseil scientifique sur le
virus de la grippe qui estime que
l'hypothèse d'une épidémie doit être
considéré cette année notamment à cause
d'un déficit d'immunité collective en
cause la mise sous cloche et les gestes
barrières
et moi
c'est une impression globale on a
l'impression d'avoir un petit peu plus
de rhume depuis mars nous avons été en
contact avec tous les virus
respiratoires grâce aux mesures pas ce
qui suit surtout à la en port du masque
et une bonne hygiène des mains depuis
quelques mois avec un petit peu la levée
des mesures barrières qui est partial on
se retrouve confronté à ces virus bien
qu'ils aient contribué une baisse
d'immunité les professionnels de santé
estiment que les gestes barrière ne sont
pas à écarter d'autant que la paire
d'immunité engendré restent marginaux
chez les adultes je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient de grandes conséquences de ces 18
mois on va dire de protection ce qu'on
va voir chez les adultes c'est plutôt
quelques cas de koffi 19 qui vont
réapparaître
parce que l'immunité global ben va un
petit peu
s'amenuiser pour certaines personnes
malgré pas que ça hein certains vont un
petit peu perdre d'une immunité en
attendant une troisième dose lavage de
mains port du masque brassage de la
population
parallèlement à l'extension de la
vaccination contre le coc vie 19 la
proportion de français qui respecte les
gestes barrière s'érode régulièrement
selon une enquête réalisée par kobe prev
59% des personnes interrogées en
septembre 2021 10 se laver régulièrement
les mains contre 63 pour cent au mois de
mai par ailleurs elles étaient 72 % à
salluit sans serrer la main au mois de
mai 2021 un autre 50 9% au mois de
septembre reste que la plupart des virus
respiratoires saisonniers se
transmettent sur un mode gouttelettes
épidémiologistes et professionnels
s'accordent il est primordial de
conserver les gestes barrières afin de
juguler ces maladies
[Musique]